when was the dot-com bubble
i can't even remember when it was that's
a bad sign
wouldn't that have been around like 2003
let me look it up before i say something
totally silly
it shows how much i
i thought it was like yeah 2003 oh okay
nevermind i'm just gonna be quiet
it shows how involved that was with that
um
okay
all right let's go ahead and go live
for kids and others and i think we had a
few questions left over from
last week um
let's see it was a question here where
were you
in the dot-com bubble burst and
uh was your wisdom needed then
you know it takes me a moment to even
remember when the dot-com bubble was
um which is kind of a sign that it
wasn't such a big deal for me so
so i started my company well from
research in 1986
which is an outrageous 34 years ago now
and we
first released mathematica which is
the kind of uh uh
which is the the the same story as
wolfram language
we first released that in 1988 um
and uh we've been developing it ever
since
and we're about to bring out version
12.2 of it
um it seems like every new version we
bring out even these point one versions
um are uh there's more and more and more
stuff that ends up getting put in it's
kind of been an accelerating story
for 34 years which is a pretty long time
to be accelerating for
but um back around i think the the big
run-up of the dot-com
uh bubble was kind of the first wave of
of uh you know the internet
it's cool there's things going on um
was the late 1990s up until about 2000
2003
uh that period of time actually
corresponded to a period of time when i
was working on a basic science project
so i had i started in 1991
working on this project which turned
into my book a new kind of science
about exploring kind of the
computational approach
to understanding sort of everything in
the world so to speak but particularly
understanding the sort of computational
universe of simple programs maybe i'll
talk about that another time
but i that turned out to be a project
where i thought gosh i'm going to spend
a year or so on this
along with running my company but it
turned out i just discovered a lot more
than i expected
to discover and that ended up being a 10
and a half year
adventure which finally finished in may
2002
so it finally released this book at that
time and then
um at that time my my main activity in
addition to running the company
um was uh trying to explain to people
what was in that book
um and um so i'm not sure how much i
even noticed the
the the dot-com bust so to speak because
i was
our company makes tools
that get used by lots of people in r d
and now increasingly lots of people
building production grade systems of
various kinds
but um my theory tends to be when
when um when the world is in not so good
shape
people are thinking more and that means
they tend to use our tools that help
people think
more so we tend to be a little bit
counter cyclical
in terms of of um what happens with them
with our tools but for me um 2003 or so
i was mostly explaining to people what
new kind of science was about
and then i was gradually starting to
realize that that on the basis of the
the scientific ideas that i'd had there
that an idea that i'd
actually been thinking about since i was
a kid about computational knowledge
was something that should be possible
and that turned into the building of
wolfman alpha
which started around 2004 or so so
so i think at that that period of time
my um
my main interest was uh in making use of
the science that i built
and then um and then transitioning to
this project which at first seemed like
an absolutely impossible project to
making
a system that could kind of ingest
the knowledge of the world make it
something that a computer could deal
with
and make it so that a computer could
answer questions on the basis of that
but that's what we
uh succeeded in in releasing in in 2009
and now gets used um
all over the place so i think the answer
is that i
i was um surprisingly unaware of the of
the dot-com
bubble and and bust um because
uh the nature of our business i suppose
is uh
measured more on the multi-decade time
scale than it is on the individual what
happens at a particular year time scale
um let's see
the um
oh boy we got another history question
here right i'll do one more history
question we'll go back and
and um do some other ones this is from
parmenides
um what work did i do at bell labs who
did i meet there
gosh you're asking me you know this is
uh usually i would be able to
go back and look at my archive and see
things but i'm going to i'm going to do
this from memory so it won't be quite as
perfect as it might be
um but uh um
as back in 1983
um right
yeah 1983. um
and uh i was um moving from caltech
to the institute for advanced study in
princeton and i spent a few months as a
consultant at bell labs
in murray hill new jersey bell labs was
the
the um the research center of
att the sort of then not yet broken up
phone company and it was probably the
most
the largest scale uh research and
development organization
in the world at that time um it was kind
of the
the the the side of the fact that the
phone company was kind of a monopoly
everybody had to get their phone from
from at t and it was it was kind of was
kind of reminds one of some of the
things that happened today with social
media and so on but it was kind of like
you can't if even if you had a physical
phone
physical phone that didn't come from att
you were not allowed to plug it into the
wires
that that att had run to your house so
to speak
uh now i think originally that was
because they were worried that
if you plug the phone into the the their
wires
you could just blow up their phone
system or you could for example do
things like you could
uh take electric power from the phone
system
um and sort of bring the whole thing
down and so on and it used to be a very
funky system because
the electrical wires you know people
have so
so when when you have a um
uh an electrical outlet you're getting
in the us
um 220 volt
uh alternating current uh electricity
from that
um if if you have a wired uh
phone then most of the time when
you're not talking on the phone or
anything there's
there's very little uh electricity going
through the wires that are
are the wires associated with your wired
phone
um when uh i think it's uh what is it
maybe 12 volts or something
um normally but um in in something which
is kind of a bizarre hack and i don't
know whether it still
works this way uh when the phone would
ring
you know literally it would it would
have a little ringer thing and it would
go you know
would would ring when when you got a
phone call
they put 100 volts through the phone
line
to get your phone to ring so to speak
and uh
you know so so i think one of the things
they're worried about is oh my gosh
people will just take that hundred volts
that they get for the phone ringing and
so on and you know use that to power
i don't know what but but many reasons
why why one could imagine that would be
kind of uh sort of bad news for people
just plug random things into the phone
network
um but any case the result of of all
this was the phone
system was kind of a complete monopoly
and there was just one place
in the u.s where you get phones from in
many countries the government ran the
phone organization some countries
still does um and uh there isn't a
private
phone phone company so to speak but
anyway
the the sort of the benefit of the fact
that uh sort of all phones ran through
at
t was that att had a huge budget for
doing research and development and they
they made a big effort to do that and uh
the result
of that effort was the invention of
transistor and
all sorts of other um all sorts of other
really
important innovations um in uh in the
history of technology
but um anyway when i was there um it was
sort of in the
in the probably still in the in the
golden age of um
of bell labs it was a very big building
i i always used to think that
they had these very straight corridors i
always used to think that the the theory
of it was if anybody thought they could
uh
compete it's like well let us show you
our research and development
organization you know there's a corridor
that goes so far you can't even see it
at the other end of it
um but uh it was uh they had
spent a lot of effort trying to
understand how to manage
research and development well and how to
take people who were technically
sophisticated and and who had an
interest in doing management and turn
them into people who could do management
and so on
as uh i would say was from what i could
see it was a pretty well-run
organization
um the people i interacted with kind of
three groups of people that are
physicists mathematicians and computer
science people
the computer science folks were the unix
group unix
which is the operating system behind
which is now
linux is is sort of a clone of unix
and uh the mac operating system for
example also comes from
a clone of unix uh that came out of
carnegie mellon university
um operating system called mark um
but uh uh back in the um in the early
1980s unix was still being developed
about labs
um that they unix was originally
developed as a an operating system to uh
uh be run on telephone switching uh uh
equipment i mean basically what happens
in a in a large
uh you know telephone wires come into
this big place
and if somebody if person a wants to
call person b
fundamentally you have to get the the uh
the electrical signal that comes in on
wire a
and somehow you have to get that
electrical signal to go out on wire b
and so there have been a bunch of
technologies for doing that the earliest
were kind of electromechanical switches
where you literally
uh well the the very earliest were
non-automated exchanges where people
would have
where telephone operators would have
this this big plug board
of you know you get a wire from person a
you're connecting it into a socket from
that goes to person b and that's how you
connect a phone call
and a lot of our uh language about
connecting a phone call
is really all about literally the
operator pulling out the wire
and putting it in the in the place to
make that connection then in the um
probably 1950s in the us i think
um 1940s to 1950s uh
yeah electromechanical switching
actually no it happened in the uk
for example it had already happened by
the time of the second world war there
was already
a bunch of electromechanical switching
that was being done
by the phone company in the uk and
probably in the us
also where electromechanical switches
were instead of a human picking up the
wire and connecting it somewhere
it was that something from the phone
had told the switching equipment oh
we're calling such and such a number
um so set the the uh
uh set the system so that it would
go um so that it would uh
physically make a connection from this
place to that place by by
moving relays by by having electrical
signals that move relays
that then make the connection uh from
person a to person b
and i think um uh i don't know whether
uh i'm this is the the difficulty of the
fact that i grew up in england a long
time ago
and um i i not sure i've used these
terms since i lived there so i don't
completely know if the american terms
are the same
but there was this notion of standard
trunk dialing
so one of the issues was when you make a
local call
if you're in your very local area that
really that could be achieved
by having you know a phone operator
basically
uh you know they just have a big
switchboard of
here here all the subscribers you know a
few thousand of them
here and you literally put a wire from
one to another but clearly if you're
doing that for the whole country or the
whole world that's that's absolutely not
possible
and so the idea was that there would be
these trunk lines
where from the local phone
exchange you would then connect to a
trunk line which would be a long line
that would go from you know new york to
san francisco or something
then at the other end a phone operator
would kind of pick up
uh that that would take that that wire
and kind of connect it to um uh to the
particular person you were calling
so um uh but but the so the first step
was to automate
the um uh automate different stages of
this
and to automate um uh what you sent
over the over the kind of long distance
phone line to tell the operator at the
other end what to connect to and
and all those kinds of things and and
that kind of stuff gradually came in i
think in the 1940s 1950s
um and so on by the time i was around in
england in the 1960s i think pretty much
all of the local exchanges
there were no humans involved it was all
electromechanical switching equipment
but then there was a new idea the new
idea was to use computers to do
switching
and the one of the ideas
was to use so-called virtual circuits
where you would do things like you would
have um
essentially i mean that there's sort of
the early days of things like computer
networks like ethernet and things like
this but it was
long before ethernet um it was ideas
like uh you know you would sort of put
all the data
into this one electrical bus where or
essentially wire and you would do things
like you would say okay
you get the time slot between uh you
break all
times up into let's say a thousandth of
a second you get
the first thousandth of a thousandth of
a second and you compress all your data
and put it there
and that represents the conversation for
a thousandth of a second or something
and then you say okay person a
uh to communicate with person b they're
gonna pick
time slot 27 and they both know that
they're dealing with time slot 27
and so the data from everybody is thrown
onto the same bus
but person b knows and person a both
know
they're taking that particular time slot
out of
out of these various slices of time um
that are made available
so that was kind of an idea and and
there were subsequent ideas but the big
thing that
um that happened uh around late 1960s
1970 or so
was the idea of really using computers
general purpose computers to control
that switching
uh capability and so unix was developed
as a an operating system for computers
to enable that kind of switching
to be done and it was originally
developed really just to run
on telephone switching equipment but
then it was realized that actually
it can be used for lots of other things
and bell labs pretty much said well
we'll just give it away
to use for other things we don't really
care about other things we only care
about the
the unix rt the real-time version of
unix
that was going to be used for telephone
switches um
but uh i remember when i was there the
uh well so
as i recall there were these series of
generations of
uh ess's electronic switching system uh
things and i think
i think um in a rough approximation you
know there would be the number four ess
number five number six number seven
and i think roughly they were going up
in factors of 10 in size
and so by the time you were dealing with
the new york city central switching
system you know it was switching 10
million lines or something it would be a
number seven one or whatever
i think it was also in generations of of
when those devices were produced i don't
i don't recall all the details of it
but i do remember when i was when i was
there there had been um
uh i think it was when i was there maybe
it was slightly before that i'm not sure
um there had been a uh uh some kind of
strike or something among the people who
worked in the telephone switching
uh facility
in in new york city for example and
the researchers at bell labs were very
keen they were like oh my gosh we're
going to get to go into this
actual you know closed building that is
the central telephone switch
because something might go wrong but
actually the the equipment was built
with a lot of redundancy and i think
over a few week period
simply nothing failed um or if it if if
things failed there was enough
redundancy that another device
was sort of automatically put into into
operation
um and no human had to be involved in
going in and replacing anything
um but uh that was a time when
when um well the unix operating system
uh
um uh ken thompson and dennis ritchie
were the two people
who had been involved in building that
and i certainly
knew both of those people um and uh
the um i think uh they'd also been
involved in um
the c programming language um and brian
kernighan
uh was a person who was also bell labs
at that time and
uh wrote a uh the nice sort of early
book on um
on the c programming language along with
dennis ritchie
i mean kind of the and again i'm now
going into history which is
probably not for the young but anyway i
mean um
what's sort of interesting that dennis
richie had
done a phd in theoretical computer
science um before he had uh come to bell
labs i think he worked on regis
register machines actually which
strangely sort of resonate with the kind
of thinking that goes into the c
programming language
um but uh oh gosh who all
all sorts of other people i i uh
knew at bell labs both people in the in
the kind of unix area
um and uh people who were involved with
kind of um
uh you know early computer security
stuff like i remember ken thompson
talking about how um
uh how he just called up a bunch of um
um people who had unix systems
and said you know on the phone hello i'm
ken thompson
you know can you tell me the the um the
root password for your system
and bunch of them did and that was kind
of an early experiment in kind of social
engineering for computer security
because
obviously that was a super bad idea if
somebody just calls you on the phone
and says what's the root password for
your computer system
it's like really bad idea in general to
to
to give the answer to that um but it was
sort of interesting that he he tried
that experiment
um just to see what would happen um
but uh yeah lots of other people i could
tell you about math people and physics
people but i think this is
there's too much in the category of um
of history um and uh
uh yeah so my own my own
uh work about labs was mostly
mostly um i was working on cellular
automata and mathematical kinds of
things
um all right let's see
uh
there's a question here from d0 was it
need in the phone grid
that drove innovation of the transistor
i believe the answer to that is yes
i believe that transistors were so
what was there before transistors there
were
uh there were electromechanical switches
but then there were purely electronic
switches that were based on vacuum tubes
and so what is a vacuum tube it's this
thing usually they're quite big
they're you know these glass um in
british english they used to be called
valves in american english they're
called vacuum tubes
the glass with a vacuum inside
and the most common kind was thing
called triode
and a triode um the idea was
that in a vacuum when you heat a wire up
eventually it will start emitting
electrons when you heat the wire up
eventually there's a sort of a stream of
electrons that get produced
and what's happening is in this in this
triode device
is that you are getting the stream of
electrons and you have sort of a
a a mesh that they have to go through
and depending on whether there's a
voltage on that mesh or not
they'll either go through or they won't
and that's a way to make essentially an
electrical switch
using those kinds of techniques but the
way that you had to make that electrical
switch
involved having this this glass
thing that was had vacuum inside and it
was quite big and it
it operated with quite high voltages of
hundreds of uh actually
even even thousands of volts in the end
and there were things that got hot and
it was it was just a big mess
and the uh the mean time between
failures
uh was quite short and things would um
you know
that what would happen is you know the
hot wire would get so hot that
it would get some defect and it would
then it would break and
all kinds of different things would
happen and so it was kind of unreliable
and these vacuum tubes are very
expensive to produce
so there was a big push is there a way
of doing switching
that does not use this you know really
kind of complicated piece of physics
and complicated things so the transistor
uses semiconductors
and transistors can be very very very
small i mean they can be made
in the um uh down to
um millionths of a meter
um that the length scales now are on the
order of
six six-ish millionths of a meter is
kind of the the feature size
well actually the feature size from
transistor is a little bigger than that
but it's it's
it's um um it's like 100
000 of a meter um is
is a typical kind of uh size of a
transistor as it appears on
on a microprocessor uh integrated
circuit chip
or something so they can be made very
very small the the early transistors
were
that small they were they were you know
they would usually maybe be a centimeter
across but
but they also nothing there wasn't
anything that got hot inside there was
nothing that had to have a vacuum inside
it was just something you made out of
semiconductors and um
uh it was a a pure sort of solid-state
device there was no
vacuum in it there was nothing et cetera
et cetera et cetera so it was a much
much better way to do electronic
switching now people have wondered
um ever since the um the invention of
the transistor is there yet a better way
to do it
and for example one thing there's the
thing called the memristo which is
another
kind of approach there are ideas that
are based on
kind of quantum scale devices that are
possible transistor-like things that
these things called joseph's injunctions
which were one thing that um
uh was popular at a time and is now used
in
in some designs of quantum computers
joseph's injunctions are
are very cool in two senses of the word
both they're an interesting idea
and they have to be cooled to the
temperature of liquid helium
in order to work um they work using this
phenomenon called superconductivity
that can explain that i mean basically
actually superconductivity the theory of
how superconductivity
worked was another thing that was uh
developed
i guess that was developed to bell labs
um
the uh anyway the the
uh okay this is a little bit of a side
track but perhaps interesting to people
what is a superconductor
so so normally in um when you have
a um a piece of wire for example
and you're trying to put an electric
current through it what does it mean to
put an electric current through it it
means there are electrons that
you're sort of at one end of the wire
you're kind of progressively pushing
electrons through the wire
the electrons will will um uh will be
moved through the wire
electric uh the voltage is the kind of
force that pushes the electrons the
current is the number of electrons that
are flowing through the wire
and the re resistance of the wire
is the kind of how much force you have
to put
in order to get a certain amount of
current in order to get a certain flow
of electrons through the water
and so any material will have a certain
resistivity
a certain amount of resistance per unit
volume etc etc etc
and and so any particular material will
have that resistivity resistivities vary
by huge amounts by factors of a trillion
between different kinds of materials so
there are insulators
where it's super difficult you have to
put you know
millions of volts across the thing
before it will usually
break down the material to get them to
get current to go through it to get
electrons to go through it and then
there are other materials
metals typically where electrons just
wander around
very freely and you don't need to put a
lot of voltage
on to get the current to flow through
the material
and so those those things have low
resistivity metals have low resistivity
but they still have some resistivity so
if you have a copper wire for example
copper is a metal that's a good
electrical conductor
if you have a copper wire then you can
put a certain voltage on it let's say
you put
um uh 220 volts for example on it
it's like how long a a copper wire
you know what is the resistance of a
copper wire how much
how long a copper wire can you have
while still getting a certain flow of
electrons a certain current through it
based on a voltage of let's say 220
volts now by the way you can have longer
and longer lengths of copper wire
and still get current through it the
higher the voltage you have
and that's why for example when you see
power lines that are going a long
distance
they have higher voltages um because
that that's a way to
sort of get more current through the
wires um
and actually there are some some other
effects that i'm not that i'm ignoring
slightly here about
about um heat dissipation and so on but
but let's ignore that
for now but the basic point is that in
in
materials like copper there's a certain
to
there's a certain resistance there's a
certain resistivity to the material
okay so back around 1910 or so
uh it was discovered that if you make a
metal um
i think uh niobium tin
i think these were the first ones that
were discovered if i remember correctly
if you make these metals really really
cold
then it turns out that's a strange thing
happens
instead of them their resistance goes
down and down and down and then suddenly
the resistance goes to zero like there's
no resistance
you can you just have to any electron as
soon as you get it started it'll just go
freely through the material and so that
um
that it's it's like when you know when
something like water
uh uh freezes into ice there's a phase
transition
suddenly at a temperature let's say zero
degrees centigrade um
the water you know any liquid water will
freeze into ice
similarly with a superconductor um you
have a transition
at a certain temperature at which the
superconductor instead of having
a a certain resistance a certain
resistivity will go to zero resistance
um and so a superconductor has this
feature that if you have something
at that lower temperature these are
temperatures close to
absolute zero so temperature is
determined by
kind of the the how fast atoms in a
material are running around how much
kinetic energy is
associated with the atoms in a material
that's what determines temperature
so that means as you as you make the
temperature lower and lower and lower
the atoms get slower and slower and
slower until eventually essentially the
atoms have stopped
at absolute zero absolute zero is minus
273.16 or something
degrees centigrade um they don't quite
stop because of quantum effects but
in a first approximation there's no more
the the
the atoms are just sort of stationary
they're not running around which is what
temperature makes them do
um i i again footnote they're not it's
not quite true because of
because of quantum zero point energy
which makes them not quite be stationary
but they're as stationary as they'll
ever get
so in any case what happens is
in a superconductor um below a certain
temperature
the um uh you get um
a uh you get this transition to
uh any voltage will successfully push
electrons through the material
so that means you can if you have a
superconducting a ring of superconductor
you can actually have electric current
circulating on that ring for months
years even people have done that if you
keep the thing cold enough
there's just no resistance to those
electrons just keeping on circulating
normally what will happen in a material
is the electrons will be going through
it
and they'll keep on hitting
imperfections in the material
and those imperfections in the material
will deflect the electrons effectively
and stop them just going the direction
the voltage said they should go
but when you make the temperature cold
enough in a superconductor
roughly that's not what happens roughly
there are
the the um the number of sort of
imperfections gets small enough
that um there isn't sort of resistance
to motion of the electrons actually the
true story is a little bit more
complicated than that
um the true story is that um in a
superconductor it's a quantum mechanical
effect
that allows um okay it's a little
complicated these things that are called
cooper pairs
that are formed which are pairs of
electrons and these pairs of electrons
have the property that they have their
quantum mechanically
things called bosons um which means that
they have the quantum mechanical feature
that they all sort of want to get
together in the same state once you have
some electrons some electron pairs
that are that all sort of want to go in
a particular direction
more electrons will want to join that
pack that's a feature of the quantum
mechanics
of particles like that um is that
they'll all sort of want to join the
pack and go in the same direction
the other big phenomenon that works the
same way is lasers
lasers involve photons particles of
light that want to sort of
have this feature that they're bosons
and they like to get together and all go
in a pack
and that's kind of why you get sort of
this coherent beam of laser light
in a superconductor what's happening is
you're essentially getting a coherent
uh uh sort of herd of electrons
uh not quite a beam of electrons because
it's it's inside a material et cetera et
cetera et cetera but a coherent
um sort of a coherent collection of
electrons that all sort of want to do
the same thing
and all kind of support each other in
keeping on maintaining that electric
current and not letting it get
uh deflected away and so on so anyway
superconductors
um are uh
so one feature of superconductors is
they have um they have these currents
persistent currents
there are also some features of
superconductors that have do a magnetic
field and that's
i was talking about joseph's injunctions
that's how they work and they involve
oh this is going to get me too far
afield uh a
quantization of magnetic field um in
in loops of superconductor and so on i
mean just on the subject to
superconductors one of the biggest news
is
okay people use superconducting magnets
okay people you can make a bigger magnet
if you can have if you can use a
superconductor to just maintain this
very high
current which produces a large magnetic
field and so some mri machines for
example
that want to have very large magnetic
fields
will use superconductors and will have
magnets that are
cooled to very low temperatures one of
the things that's been a long running
effort is can one make a room
temperature superconductor
can one make a superconductor that one
could like use to make a magnetically
levitated train or something like this
come on have a super conductor
that is still super conducting at room
temperature because the superconductors
we know
are super conducting you know a few
degrees above absolute zero
at temperatures where where certainly
air is liquid
um but actually more than that helium
which is is one of the
the loss to liquify substances
um you have liquid helium and um that's
what you use actually as a coolant
typically for
for superconductors and the question is
can one get
room temperature superconductors
nobody's succeeded in doing that about
uh 30 years ago now
so-called high-temperature
superconductors were found which are
materials that make it
to what is it tens of of degrees above
absolute zero
and um the uh and that those those are
quite um uh slightly exotic materials
and
and it's still not really understood
exactly how high
temperature superconductivity works it
wasn't known at the beginning when
superconductivity was discovered
it took a solid 50 years 40 years 50
years
between the time when superconductivity
was discovered as a phenomenon
to the time when it was explained
theoretically and high temperature
superconductors still one doesn't know
and someone doesn't really know if
there's some strange substance
that um if one could only figure it out
would suddenly make high temperature
room temperatures superconductors
and then we would have all these devices
we had would suddenly have
superconductors in them
and that would be pretty cool and there
are all kinds of interesting things that
one could do that way
all kinds of useful things for electric
power distribution all kinds of things
for lots of different purposes
um the uh in fact the high temperature
superconductors that are known now
are somewhat exotic materials for
example one of the things that
uh chemical element lanthanum was one
that is not used for very many things
but it was
that's an element that appeared in the
at least in the early high temperature
superconductors um
so i think we're we're way off topic
because we were talking about some
um uh
gosh we're talking about some um
uh how did i get into this we were
talking about
um oh transistors and switching networks
and so on and um
and that's just a different direction is
if you could get if superconductors were
easy to have
there were a bunch of new kind of
switching stuff that that would be
possible
um let's see
uh there's a question from philip here
how many shirts do i own that's a good
question i was i wonder about that
someone i don't know it's not
it's on the uh by physicist orders of
magnitude
it's of of order tens
by which i i think um certainly not
um um and the question is do i wear a
different shirt every time i do one of
these um
um one of these um episodes i i have no
idea i have not um
that's a piece of data analytics that
will be easy to do based on looking at
the youtube videos or whatever
um uh will be will be easy thing to do
in more from language i haven't done it
i guess i'm not that interested in that
um uh
oh yeah the let's see
um well lots of questions here lots of
interesting things
there's a question from david here are
there string theorists who believe that
nature is finite and digital
you know that's one of those questions
which couldn't possibly be answerable
by because i don't know how many string
theorists there are in the world i i
would guess the number is
um active string theorists
probably a few hundred um maybe as many
as a thousand but i would guess it's in
the few hundred
uh it's probably a it's it's a you know
it's a decreasing number
and you know do any of them believe
something is not a question that one is
going to be able to answer
um do i well i suppose one might be able
to by by saying um
uh do i know ones who believe that i i'm
pretty sure i do
um and uh in fact there's a there's a
workshop next week which has kind of
been
been uh stimulated by our physics
project
that involves mostly causal set and loop
quantum gravity people not i think
string theorists but
but maybe maybe we'll learn something
there about what what people think it's
it's hard to know
um
uh let's see oh gosh so many questions
here
um
okay there's an interesting question
from mikhail says great scientists
typically have great students
is it because something is transferred
from a teacher to a student or because
talented people
try to reach outstanding supervisors
that is a good question
um probably a mixture of those things
i think that well let me
let me describe a couple of points uh
you know when one has been successful in
a project
it's easier to be successful in another
project
so if somebody has
uh if one has somehow gotten involved in
a project that is successful
and that one is successful in that tends
to
give one the confidence to go on and try
other projects that one can be
successful in as well
so i think that's a if if somebody
happened to be
happens to be sort of close to something
great that's happening
then that's a that's a good indicator
that they'll be able to go on doing
great things
i mean i i might say that that you know
i i have been i i
i'm not been an academic or professor
for
how long is it 33 years now
third of a century that's disgustingly
long but
um so i can um but i would say that
um uh you know there are people who are
great researchers
and pretty crummy supervisors of
students
and there are people who are not
particularly great researchers but
outstanding supervisors of students
these are two sort of independent
parameters and sometimes it varies it
depends on what stage of a career
somebody
is at you know they may be at a stage in
their career
where they're really concerned with
their own research and they just don't
want to take any time
interacting with students um it's
uh um and um you know there's also
a sort of a complicated trade-off
because there are people where
they'll say they'll they want students
who are going to help them
do their own research project if their
own research project is super
interesting
and sort of spin off one of the students
gets kind of a spin-off of that project
and that you know and the whole project
is so interesting it kind of
everybody wins but the other possibility
is well
actually the the the the research budget
isn't that interesting
and the student is kind of pulled along
on a
not terribly interesting project and
they don't get to
you know use their own wings so to speak
and make their own project
whereas in other cases you know students
will
invent their own project and sometimes
they'll have a hard time
finding an advisor who says oh yeah i'm
interested in helping you with that
project or supervising you on that
project
and sometimes there are there are very
sort of structural issues like
somebody some advisor will have a a
government grant that pays for
research in a particular area and unless
a student is wants to work in that
particular area
it's like well i'm sorry i can't support
you from this from this grant that i
have so there are
sort of mechanical things like that that
happen but
um i would say that the um
uh you know in terms of the the do
it's a little complicated because there
are things where there are places
where there's sort of a hotbed of some
particular hot area that's going on and
and people students will tend to
uh you know if they're if they're sort
of ambitious for that area they'll try
and go to those places and so they'll
tend to be
aligned with kind of all the activity
that's happening there and that
that makes them more likely to to do
things that are that are seen as
exciting
i think that um uh but but you know it's
a very
um um it's such a personality dependent
thing i mean there are people
uh you know i always notice that
you know there are areas which are very
fashionable where
if you work in that area and you make a
progress in research in that area
people will immediately say if you made
progress they say oh yeah we all know
about this area we know why it's
important
and yeah you what you did is great or
not great or whatever
that's the good news about working in a
fashionable area the bad news is there
are lots of other people working in that
area too
and you're in a sense competing in this
race with lots of other people
to pick kind of whatever low-hanging
fruit or whatever things are possible
in that area so that's kind of the
fashionable area case
of you know and then there's the
unfashionable area case
where nobody is going to you know there
are no competitors
it's a it's an open thing there's no
race but then if you figure out
something you think is really really
interesting
then you gotta then you've got a whole
battle of telling people look
this thing you've never heard about
before this is really interesting
personally i'm much i'm much more
interested in the kind of unfashionable
areas um uh thing
partly because i feel like uh from a
sort of perhaps it's an egotistical
point of view
i feel like i'm making more of a
contribution if i'm doing something that
wouldn't have been done
if i hadn't done it whereas if i'm part
of a race
where lots of people are trying to do
the same thing it's like well if i don't
do it somebody else in the race will do
it
we'll do it instead so what am i really
contributing
um but that's another thing that's
that's complicated and has some
sort of complicated consequences for for
students and
um and so on i mean you know another
thing to understand
about for example graduate students is
uh you know a minority of graduate
students
invent their own projects to do for
their phd
theses or whatever the majority are
given a project by somebody
and the choice of project is a difficult
matter and
some uh some people are much better at
figuring out
potential projects than others and some
people provide much more fertile
projects for students to work on i mean
i it happens i
i we run the summer school and and high
school summer camp every year
and one of my jobs there is to come up
with projects for everybody and i'm
i'm pretty pleased with myself these
days for you know
for the projects that i managed to come
up with and i was actually just um
just noticing that a person who was at
our summer school um
uh what was it 18 years ago or something
now uh was a project
that i suggested that he turned into a
paper and many
papers and our whole career and i just
noticed he's just becoming a senior
professor somewhere
um uh sort of got going in that
direction so that was
i thought that was i was i was pretty
happy about that um
and uh but but you know it's a it's um
it's quite an art to come up with a good
project
and to be able to do that for oneself
is a is a major skill um it's a skill
that typically
does not exist in people who are sort of
just going to graduate school when it
does exist
it's great well it's great so long as
the project you really want to do
is a project that you can find an
advisor who says oh yeah
i'm happy to work with you on that
project rather than oh well i can't
really support you on that project
because my grant does this
and i'm really only interested in that
and i really want you to be kind of a
research assistant for my project type
thing
so it's it's a bit of a um a bit of a
complicated story there
um but uh you know i do think that
um in terms of um um
well there's another phenomenon which
happens in sort of the education
particularly in the kind of
high achieving researchy end of things
which is just seeing that other people
invent something and do something
that becomes you know that's that's sort
of highly visible in the world
just seeing something go from nothing to
something is extremely educational so to
speak
or just knowing that i don't know when
when i was
when i was a kid i was studying physics
and things and and you know i
i knew all these names of all these
physicists and so on and then a few
years later when i was a late teenager
actually i
well mid to late teenager i started
meeting these people and it's like
you know before that had just been a
name of some you know some famous name
of some invented who invented some
physics thing or whatever else
and then it was very interesting to kind
of get to know these people as people
and to realize yeah well these are just
people too and you know
they get some things right they get some
things wrong there's nothing
you know magic and sort of uh offered a
distance about what's going on there
it's something that you know i can
imagine doing it too and if you're
around
some uh something where somebody even
somebody else
is going for well i have this crazy idea
and then
you hear about it being developed and
then suddenly it's this big thing in the
world
that's a neat thing to see and um i
think that uh you know i've i've been
fortunate enough
to have done that process of going from
that's
you know the crazy idea that i come up
with to something that's a
big thing in the world so to speak i've
had the good fortune to do that a bunch
of times in my life
and uh i always think it's nice when
other people are kind of involved or at
least con
sort of seeing what's going on because i
think it is really quite
empowering to see this process of going
from i just have an idea
to this is a thing that's a real thing
in the world that
people are making use of
um
gosh so many questions here it's taking
even them
um
okay there's a question here from
mr wololo can't quite read it but anyway
what age do you think is the best age to
start coding
and why so
it's a good question uh
you know i think the most important
thing to learn for most people
is how to think computationally it's
more important than the mechanics of how
to write a piece of code or whatever
else
um and uh you know i've spent a large
part of my life
trying to build this computational
language that we have that tries to
make it as easy as possible for us
humans to express
ourselves computationally and get our
computers to do things
that that particular activity is a bit
different from the typical kind of
programming language
you know c java python whatever
programming language activity
which is let me talk to a computer in
its own language
and get the computer to do things that
computers intrinsically do
what we're interested in and well from
language and in making a sort of
full-scale computational language
is to be able to talk to a computer
about
i don't know cities or movies or
whatever else and have the computer
already know
lots of stuff about cities and movies
and how to compute lots of things and
how to make
uh you know process images in this way
and that way and the other
in other words have something where
there's sort of computational
intelligence built into the computer
and where our challenge is to use
computational language
to express ourselves to our computer so
that the computer can use its
computational intelligence
to give us back things we want to know
about
and so you know i think the the um to me
learning computational language learning
to express oneself computationally
learning to
to think about things in a way that can
be explained to a sufficiently smart
computer
that's the thing that pretty much 100
percent of people should know how to do
that's the computational literacy that
people need that's the
that's the analog of the sort of basic
mathematical literacy
that people need it's the analog of of
literacy
in uh in in in writing in natural
language english or whatever else
that people need um that's the thing
people need
being able to write low-level computer
code where you know
how to allocate memory and define loops
and and
you know check pointers and things like
this that's a very small fraction of
people that need that
um that's that's for the kind of uh you
know the the
the sophisticated low-level engineers um
uh low-level in the sense that they're
dealing with
sort of the infrastructure of the world
way below
what most people need to worry about
most people you know are going to just
use a cell phone they don't need to know
the packet structure
of you know how um how data is sent on
on you know through a cell phone network
and how the uh
how all that stuff works and most people
you know who drive cars for example
you know the number of people who need
to know how the car engine works and how
to change
even these days how to change a tire or
something is
is gone down and down um that stuff has
been sort of automated away what you
need to know
is the part that is sort of the human
goal of which way do i want to cut
drive the car what what do i do with the
you know what i want to do with the car
so to speak rather than
you know what are the low-level
operation of the car in its sort of
internal engineering
so i think the the important thing is
they're learning this kind of
computational thinking
how do you express yourself in terms of
computational thinking
and um my observation is you know i
wrote this little book called elementary
introduction to wolfram language
and i did that partly on the basis of um
uh
i've quite a few years now i've i've had
sort of a hobby of trying to teach
actual kids
uh sort of computational thinking kinds
of things
and that's that's a good hobby if you're
interested in kind of uh
presenting kind of computational
thinking education to the world
because you quickly with kids get to
know
you know is what you're doing actually
sensible or not um
and uh i think that the um
uh that's that sort of gradually helped
me to to uh
to to sort of sharpen the exposition and
um and the things that one can do
but basically my observation is i think
around
age 10 or 11 seems to be the age at
which
kids so so that's an age at which kids
can type
uh on a computer these days um they
don't have trouble
kind of um you know with the sort of
mechanics of doing that
and then it's also a thing that teachers
often think is oh my gosh
the kid is going to have to learn the
syntax for expressing
themselves to the computer well actually
kids don't have much trouble with that
particularly because you know in our
systems for example
we are giving many affordances we're
we're helping you know we have auto
completion we have color coding
you know syntax coloring we have all
kinds of things that kind of
give one and we're actually going to
have more and more of that to kind of
give one feedback so it's like a
a super version of a spell checker um
because it knows a lot more about the
the the meaning of what you're trying to
say so it's able to give a lot more
information
as feedback so i think age around age 10
or 11 kids don't seem to have trouble
with the mechanics of sort of entering
things and
i think what happens then is what's
really important is that the first
things they do with kind of
computational language
actually do something they find
interesting you know do something with
colors with sounds with maps
with things like this you know saying
write a loop that generates
uh you know i don't know prime numbers
or something is well that might be
interesting to some kids but it's
i would say that's not uh you know
that's not top of the list
in terms of of really engaging with
things and and the the sort of the
richness of actually doing computational
thinking about
real things in the world is is very very
great and i think that's
that's sort of the place to start and i
think that age is a is a pretty decent
age to start at
now it's an interesting question as
things get more more streamlined you
know
at one stage it's just like saying okay
you learn how to
take an image and do emit some you know
blur the image
change the colors in the image that's
all pretty straightforward maybe you
learned how to make a table
of of things and so on that's all pretty
straightforward
by the time you're doing more
sophisticated kind of transformations on
data
um by the time you're doing more
sophisticated operations
uh you know what does that ramp look
like um
it's kind of an interesting thing and i
i don't think i know all the answers to
that actually let me
make another point which is people
sometimes say well let's get started
with programming
you know coding whatever computational
thinking whatever
much earlier than age 10. well i think
that was more important in the past than
it is today
because the truth is today most kids
unless they've been
sort of uh you know forced away from
technology
um or for some reason really really
don't have access to technology
you know they've used uh all kinds of
user interfaces all kinds of games and
so on
which have those kinds of basic sort of
algorithmic common sense thinking
they're already doing those things i
mean in the past
there were things like logo and scratch
and so on which were kind of junior
computer languages
that were intended for for kids to kind
of um
uh get some experience with having
computers do things and at the time when
logo was developed for example
in the 1960s it was spectacular because
the idea that a kid could walk up to a
computer and get the computer to do
something
was a really new idea and a really
important idea and and really something
empowering to kids to see
but in today's world every kid knows
they can get a computer to do
stuff and the question is can they get a
computer to do things
that are sort of interesting to them i
think that
uh you know sometimes you know you can
you can certainly use scratch to make
animations things like that which are
which are kind of fun and and that's not
a bad thing to do
um but uh in terms of learning sort of
that's a fine thing to do to just make
things with it
but in terms of of really learning
something fundamental about
computational thinking i don't really
see
that that's helping much over what one
ambiently gets from just
experience with with the sort of the
typical user interfaces and computers
that just exist today
i think the real place where you start
really engaging with sort of the
the computational thinking literacy is
when you're really actually using
computational language and really
telling the computer
to do something and what's what's really
neat is that you know in in the effort
that we've made to build well from
language and so on
it's uh we you know we've we've gone
through all this effort to sort of
automate things to the point where
it's it's easy enough to use that sort
of
the world's most advanced researchers
and so on can use it
to to do things which are sort of on the
frontier but it also
turns out that that sort of ease is also
what makes kids
have it find it accessible so i you know
anyway
my my basic answer is age 10 or 11 is is
sort of the place where that seems to be
seems to start to be to be realistic now
you know as one gets to more complicated
concepts
you know does that require greater age
it's a really interesting question so
so one of my favorite examples is higher
order functions or
um uh things like landers or
what we call an um
what we call pure functions um things
where
you have a a whole sort of um
uh you have a whole construction that is
being applied
to data uh whether whether construction
where you're treating
a program as a piece of data and you're
sort of building up this program as a
piece of data and then applying it to
data and so on
that's a concept that in my experience
people
don't find that easy to get and it takes
maybe on average being a bit older for
people to really get that concept i mean
i think it's like you can in principle
teach calculus to a
you know to a 10 year old but it's
actually a bit difficult because some of
the concepts
are a bit abstract and tend to for
whatever reason
us humans are not don't seem to be very
well wired
when we're really young to deal with
with very abstract concepts at least
that's the way it seems i mean there's
certainly been theories
about education that say that that's the
case i don't know really how accurate
those theories are i certainly asked the
person who invented
logo for example who had sort of the
earliest and longest running experience
whether he had a sense of of um of when
kids get to understand concepts like
recursion and so on he didn't really
and i don't i don't know whether that's
um but my my anecdotal impression
is that uh it's a few years older than
that
that people start to um uh to be able to
get those things easily and i think
the thing that one has to understand is
is after we've seen a lot of examples of
not using these fancy kind of higher
order
approaches after we've seen a bunch of
those examples and once had to do a bit
of extra typing
and so on because one isn't using these
fancier things then when it's sort of
primed
once one sees the fancier thing to say
aha now i can see there's a really good
labor-saving device
if you try and feed that kind of fancy
thing to people
at the beginning they'll be like why do
i care about this weird abstract thing i
don't understand what the point is
et cetera et cetera so that that's
that's
my feeling is and you know i will also
say on the other end
okay on the other end it's like is there
an oldest age at which you can learn
computational thinking in computational
language
i think the answer that is definitively
no and i
i i was very charmed a few years ago i
um you know people occasionally send me
uh a sort of uh technical support
questions about our language
and um i'm not the best place to send
them by any means because
they have a whole infrastructure for
answering people's questions but but i
get one of these things from somebody
and um i'm um some question and et
cetera et cetera et cetera and i'm
i'm kind of about to send it along to
technical support
when i notice that the person says and i
want to use this for a presentation that
i'm going to give at my 100th birthday
party
so um that got my attention and uh
turned out to be a
distinguished oceanographer actually who
who who died
uh at the age of maybe 101 102 but
um uh but it was i was very charmed that
that um
uh you know we've had a certain number
of age 100
or more users of of our computational
language
and what i found interesting um is
you know i i've seen quite a lot of
people uh you know i don't think
i mean i like to think i'm i'm becoming
ancient these days and i like to think i
can still learn a lot of new things
but i think it's really the case that um
that it's not you know people say oh my
gosh i can't learn this i'm too old
et cetera et cetera et cetera nonsense
it's um and i've seen that in
in reality so to speak um uh plenty of
times
um the people uh sometimes it it's it's
really uh
uh there's nothing there's nothing
that's fossilized in us that's like oh
my gosh you can't learn this um
uh but people have a tendency to say oh
no no you know it's something
sort of more you know intellectually
different it has to be learnt only by
the young
um i don't think that's that's true at
all um and
uh you know i wrote this book about
elementary introduction to wolfram
language kind of
aiming at the sort of kid uh demographic
um it's turned out it's also been really
useful i think to a lot of um
adults uh even quite technically
sophisticated ones because the main
thing
that is very well there many things
about that book that are
intended to be at a low technical level
for example it doesn't assume any
knowledge of math
it also doesn't assume any knowledge of
kind of software engineering and sort of
programming ideas and so on
um but uh uh you know that that's um but
it's
it's an interesting question at what
stage uh different kinds of um
uh different kinds of things in
computational thinking are are
really uh possible i would say that in
in my observation about sort of using
wolfram language and
computational language with kids
actually i've really been amused many
times because
it's like once dealing with real world
stuff in many cases of geography or or
astronomy or whatever else and sometimes
i'm like
they understand perfectly well the
computational language and they
understand perfectly well how to
structure things
and there's some piece of general
knowledge that they just don't have
um and i think sometimes in in modern
times you know
with the sort of the emphasis in
education on you know principles rather
than rather than facts um sometimes the
facts are
really aren't there and that's a shame
because you know the facts
are the things on top of which you can
learn principles
and i think i think kind of the the uh
oh my gosh they didn't learn any facts
it's just like well it all seemed easy
to learn facts but if you really don't
feed kids any facts
they're not going to learn them and um
so sometimes that's been
more of a problem that has been the
understanding of the the sort of the
syntax
of the computational language or or even
the slightly abstract
understanding of what what uh
computational language does
okay let's see uh i need to go fairly
soon here there's so many questions but
these are
a lot of very technical questions i
think um
um
uh
okay pop amenities is talking about uh
progress in in high-temperature
superconductors that's interesting
um
okay let's let's carry it cover this one
so we got a question here from pranjul
what does it mean correlation does not
imply
causation okay you hear that you heard
that comment quite often
okay so let's say
um that uh
what would be a good example here um
let's say that you have something where
um
um black
cats it's a good example of this
um uh well let me explain the basic
point the
basic point is
something oh is so many examples why am
i not thinking one immediately
um
um
something like left-handedness
causes people to be more assertive
okay that would be a a hypothesis i
happen to be left-handed
okay so you might say this is a
hypothesis i think left-handed people
are more assertive
and you might say left-handedness causes
assertiveness
being um you know because we might have
observed
statistically if we do surveys of people
of you know how assertive they are
and are they left-handed or not then we
might say
the chance of somebody being we might
say that of
uh of um right-handed people
let's say 20 are assertive of
left-handed people
30 percent are assertive so we might say
from that
okay then we conclude left-handedness
causes assertiveness because after all
we've got more left-handed people are
assertive okay
so but but that wouldn't really be a
correct conclusion because it might be
that
something leads somebody to be
left-handed something leads somebody to
be assertive
and those things might be correlated
they might be happening together but it
isn't the case that left-handedness
causes assertiveness
um it's just that they both come from
the same cause now actually it might be
more likely
that assertiveness causes
left-handedness because
if people can be like well you know
which which hand you're going to pick up
the pen and well you have a slight
preference for the left hand but
somebody else is telling you because
most kids are right-handed i'll pick up
the pen in the right hand
and so if you're not assertive you'll
just pick it up with your right hand and
if you were only a little bit
left-handed
you'll end up being right-handed but the
question is
is it the case that the um
that kind of you know assertiveness
causes left-handedness left-handedness
causes assertiveness
or are they simply correlated in the
sense that they come together
perhaps from the same cause now
to take a much more extreme version of
this okay let's take a
a curious hypothesis today uh in the
in the time of a pandemic so there is a
here's a
here's a statement so we could say
in this time of a pandemic um
well here's a very extreme one okay
you might say that uh people get sick
because somebody transmits the virus
from one person to another
okay and so people who are you know
hanging out together
one person will get sick the other
people will also get sick
and that's because one person is
transmitting is causing
the other people to get sick by
transmitting the virus to them
okay so that's hypothesis number one
when you if you observe the facts
that people who hang out together get
sick
at you know more or less the same time
that will be a potential hypothesis
okay so another quite different
hypothesis would be
oh the virus managed to get everywhere
in the world everybody's got a small
level of virus
in them because the virus is just you
know just spread all over the place
but most people don't get sick most of
the time because their immune systems
fight off the virus
and it's only when for some reason their
immune system
is not as active that then suddenly they
erupt in actually the virus can
replicate and they suddenly get sick
okay so then we would have the
hypothesis that
maybe that it isn't the case maybe we're
just completely wrong
that the virus is transmitted person to
person maybe instead
the virus has successfully you know
infected everybody at least a little bit
and what really matters is the internal
you know immune system of each person
and can the virus you know get get up um
replicate itself without getting knocked
down by the immune system and then
maybe it's the case that the people who
are in the same environment
their immune systems or whatever it is
that causes this
uh you know maybe they uh are in a place
where i don't know uh it's very cold or
or it has
or whatever some other effect that can
affect their immune system or some other
aspect of them
and maybe all those people who live in
the same house or whatever they all get
sick at more or less the same time
and they're all getting sick because
there was something outside you know the
temperature went down their heating
broke who knows what else
and um uh and that and they and they
were
and they all got sick then and so the
the um
that would be a case where sort of
there's there's correlation they're
getting sick because they're all in the
same place
they're not getting sick because one of
them causes the others to get sick so to
speak
and um so i think the the um that's a
night you know that hypothesis is
probably not correct
um although it's interesting to try and
uh you know prove that that
hypothesis isn't correct and that's
really an example
of um of uh sort of what's the
difference between
things are merely correlated they merely
happen together
versus one thing actually caused another
thing
and usually you know you can you can try
and do experiments if you can do a
controlled enough experiment
to say um that
uh uh uh you know that that
where you could do the control
experiment to ask
if you remove this this this thing do
you
not get this other thing that will be
sign of a causation
of one thing causing another thing but
but quite often you can't do a
controlled experiment
i mean when you have questions about you
know the earth's climate
you know we've only got one earth we
can't really do experiments although
actually
this time of the pandemic has been
fairly fascinating experiment from that
point of view
because uh a bunch of things have
changed in the world and we'll be able
to see the effects of those
on all sorts of global aspects of things
like climate which will be very
interesting
and see what actually matters and what
doesn't it will give us a little bit
more clue about that
but um uh you know it's it's again when
you only have sort of
one instance to go with it's very hard
to do a controlled experiment where you
say
switch this off does that mean that this
other thing doesn't happen
switch this on then the other thing
happens what also makes that kind of
experiment more difficult
is and this happens in a lot of kind of
medical
uh testing scenarios
it's it's not that big an effect like if
you
you know five percent of people would
have gotten better anyway
so the question of whether if when you
give them the drug
uh you know 12 percent of people get
better
then you know it's a it's a somewhat
small effect it's not like
nobody gets better without the drug and
everybody gets better with the drug it's
kind of a small effect
and that's where it gets much more
complicated to trace through
you know when you change what you did
how much of an effect does it have
so that that's um i'm i'm thinking there
are probably some really much better
examples that i know
should know well because i i run into
this correlation versus causation thing
so often because it's such a common kind
of thing where people say
you know everybody who is um
ah that's a great example must be good
examples of this
it's like uh you know didn't you know
that people who do this
have that happen to them or whatever and
and you realize
it's like um uh um
you know people that you realize that
that there is some there's some common
cause to those things it's not like
the one of those things causes another
thing i mean it would be like saying um
ah gosh um
i'm i'm drawing a blank here on on great
examples and it's so frustrating because
it's one of those kinds of things where
where um this is a one of those quirks
of human memory or at least mine that
it's one of these things where
it's so common that one runs into these
things and yet
um and yet it's kind of i don't index
things by oh that's a correlation versus
causation
um issue um
so um okay i need to run off but but
there's a question here
one last question uh uh
give an example of what what i would do
with wolfram language if i were 13 years
old
well it depends what i'm interested in
when i was 13 years old i was really
interested in physics
and you know i tried to program a
computer to do
some things to do with sort of hard
spheres bouncing around
i would do that with wolfram language
and it would actually work in a way that
it didn't
uh back when i was programming an
incredibly primitive computer to do it
i would also probably i myself would
also probably do a bunch of sort of
mathematical experiments
of uh you know what happens if we have a
very simple
mathematical system or very simple
computational system what does it do
i mean i personally have liked doing
those kind of experiments all my life
for another kid who's like well you know
it might be like
making music or something they might say
well what happens if i make a random
series of notes
that's kind of a half-line program a
very trivial program to just make
a random series of notes and see you
know what does that sound like okay
let's let's make the notes be correlated
so that
we're randomly picking whether we go up
or down rather than having each note be
random what does that sound like what
does it sound like if we have
uh if we have chords there you know
between
between we're playing two notes and a
chord and so on and we go through a
progression of chords those kinds of
things that might be
the one thing or if i was interested in
um
in something like um oh i don't know uh
geography maybe i would or maybe maybe
if i was interested in sort of world
affairs
um maybe i would be looking at um things
about
countries and you know gdp per capita in
countries
and comparing them with uh i don't know
number of people who go to school in
those countries and things like that
and trying to see what i can understand
about the world from that
um or perhaps if i was interested in um
uh what other kinds of things you know
if i was interested in
making a um
[Music]
making art for example i might um
might try and um use machine learning
uh capabilities to say you know take
this photograph and style it in the
style of some particular
artist or see what i could do with with
making um
uh sort of automatically generating
various kinds of artistic things
or maybe figuring out uh if i was trying
to make
some website maybe i'd be interested in
making some website that does something
maybe i'd be making an interest in
making a website that does some
i don't know mathy thing like converts
numbers to binary or
or or does um or maybe take some
uh something like that i might um make
um
be able to you know create that by
deploying it to the cloud
or maybe i'd be interested in human
languages and i'd be curious about um
uh you know what what kind of
commonality there is between the words
for something in different human
languages these are all things that
that are easy to do with our
computational language because sort of
the
the computational intelligence that's
built into it these are all things that
are readily accessible to
to a 13 year old who who learns even a
fairly elementary amount about about
wolfram language
um and i think that the um uh um
and really what's what's really great
about these kinds of things is
okay you have one of these questions
you're curious you know
is the word for fish you know what
different
first sounds are there in the word for
fish in all the languages of the earth
and is that correlated with location on
the earth and is it
you know is the language is the word for
fish
uh somehow different or maybe shorter in
languages that come from
coastal areas of the world rather than
languages that are inland in the world
i don't know something like that but but
you know you just start generating these
questions
and the trick is to get to the point
where when you come up with a question
you're fluent enough literate enough
with computational language
that you can just go and answer that
question you can say i'm curious about
this i'm reminded i
happen to be looking at something one of
my what my
kids did a few years ago um he's done
lots of kinds of
uh it happens to be somebody who got
fluent at age probably 11 or so
um with wolfram language and is like you
know just
can can can do computational nothing i
was just looking this morning for random
reasons
at a random thing where he was looking
at aircraft safety data
there's some database out in the world
and he's like just
imported the data from this aircraft
safety database
and the question is which is the the
least safe airline i'm afraid the answer
by a huge factor is aeroflot the former
soviet
um national airline is just just uh you
know
that's a um uh hugely less less safe
than other airlines but it's a huge
factor but that that's something that
you know it's like if you're curious
about that
and you're curious you know how how does
that how what is the ranking of that
how's that gone over time
well if you're fluent with computational
language it's like tap tap tap tap
you know 15 minutes later you've got
some information about that
um and that perhaps is information
nobody has really had
uh you know in the past and um that
that's the kind of thing that sort of
curiosity leads to curiosity
when you have the possibility of using
computational language
as your kind of way of answering
questions you know you come up with a
question you answer it with a
computational language
that generates probably five more
questions and you go answer them
i think that kids do not have the idea
that they can answer questions that have
not been answered before
but this is this is a place where you
know thanks to
all the work we've done to try and build
this computational language build the
computational intelligence into it
one does have the the opportunity to
like answer questions easily
answer questions that nobody has has
answered before
maybe probably nobody has asked them
before and that's that's really an
empowering thing to do and as i said i
think
my my general theory is people people
start with a certain natural curiosity
and a natural
propensity to to ask more questions more
questions more questions
and um they often get the idea in school
oh there's only a certain amount of
knowledge you know there's this
particular
track of knowledge that you have to go
down and you can't learn that unless
you've learned this and this and this
beforehand and so on
but i don't think it's really true and i
think that what we're doing with sort of
computational intelligence and so on
is really leveling that that playing
field we're making it possible for
for you know for kids to learn new
things
to which haven't ever been learned by
anybody before
rather than just oh there's this very
specific path um that you have to learn
everything along
all right i think we've we've run out of
time here um
always always a pleasure to uh uh to
chat with people here
and um thank you for all these questions
and i i am
um uh i'd encourage uh maybe we can
segment this i think there are three
categories here
there's sort of general questions which
are sort of perhaps of interest to
everybody
there are more technical more physics-y
questions um
that maybe i can break off in a separate
um i've been doing kind of a monthly
uh q a about our physics project and
that's probably the right venue for some
of these more
more technical questions um and then
there's some questions about history and
i
i've been saying for a while and i need
to get around to doing it
that i'd be happy to do some history q
as
um i mean i i i for better or worse i
i i know a fair amount about the history
of science and technology and and um
uh at least for the last 40 something
years
there's a decent chance that i was sort
of uh
that i have first-hand knowledge so to
speak um rather than
um just knowledge from from studying the
history uh
in in um you know from a distance so to
speak
so um uh those are but i'm i'm um i
particularly
uh encourage here um kind of
uh questions about sort of how things in
the world doesn't have to be physics it
can be
biology engineering even mathematics and
so on i
i'm from uh you know try me out here
i'm i mean part of my objective is that
um
uh i think i don't know we can we can go
back and see but but i think i've been
getting better at explaining things
as i've been uh doing this every week um
and um so for me it's it's interesting
to probe into different areas
where i haven't really had to explain
stuff much before
ever um and uh um give me
uh give me a try um it's interesting for
me and hopefully it will be interesting
for you all
all right i should sign off here now
thank you very much